NAT DUCA: Everybody wants a nice
smooth web app, a nice
smooth browsing experience.
But actually doing
that is a really,
really difficult problem.
And so what we're going to be
doing at Chrome summit is both
listening to the kinds
of problems
that users are having--
that's why we want everybody
to come--
and also showing how to
architect your app to be jank
free in the first place and also
how to use our tools to
figure out what's broken when
things do go wrong.
We know that this is hard, but
what we don't know is the
kinds of looks that people want
to implement and where
our tooling falls over.
So when you come to us with a
piece of content, we want to
look at it and see where the
tools work, where the tools
don't work, and what kinds of
things we should be building
into Chrome in the future
to make that look
even better for you.
I'm Nat Duca.
I'm one of Chrome's
graphics hackers.
I look forward to busting jank
with you at the summit.